[Music]
[Applause]
Cooper flag he is uh 16 years of age and
he just announced that he's going to
Duke last week his mom and dad were good
basketball players he's got two brothers
that are pretty good basketball players
but he is uh committed to going to play
for Duke how did you decide on Duke was
there a determining Factor there
Cooper um I wouldn't really say that
there was one like determining Factor um
it was just a long process of getting to
know the coaches and then visiting the
campus a couple of times um watching
practice and it was kind of just a bunch
of things that added up and just just
seemed right did you meet coach
Kay I did what was that
like um I mean it was really cool
obviously um I mean he was really down
to earth um and it was just good to talk
to him not even about basketball but
just just kind of get to know him and
just talk to him for a little bit what
other school did you
consider uh
Yukon and meeting with uh Danny Hurley
is probably a little different than
coach shy I would imagine with
personalities yeah uh pretty different
personalities but um yeah I really I
really enjoy getting to know coach
Harley um when did you become the best
basketball player in your
family
um I don't know a time when I became the
best basketball player in my family but
I mean I think it's just kind of
happened over time yeah but do you
remember an age where you were better
than mom and dad and your brothers um
I'm I've never beat my mom in a game a
one-on-one but we haven't played since I
was in fifth grade
so Now's the Time to I think you can
take her now yeah she won't play me
anymore but can she shoot
still uh um yeah I mean the last time we
played she got hurt while we were
playing and the game never finished I
was up by one point it was eight to nine
we never finished the game and your dad
played some college basketball as well
he did yeah but but he never really
played against like against me in the
backyard or
anything what when did you realize that
maybe it was time to leave Maine and go
to play better
competition um
it was around freshman year just
throughout the year um we had you know
some schools that were asking us and
reaching out that um we were looking at
and M we had a friend that had already
come here so they were kind of already
um in our view and we were had been
watching them and I don't know can't
remember when like we decided we wanted
to but it was always just a thought um
and an option if somebody hasn't seen
you play how would you describe your
style
um I mean describing myself is kind of
hard just because I think I can do a lot
of different things depending on like
what's needed and I can play a lot of
different positions so I just think the
biggest part is just how versatile I am
and just being able to guard one through
five I can handle the ball or um can
play off the ball like it really doesn't
matter so I think that's the biggest
thing just being versatile who do you
pattern your game
after nobody in particular um I watch a
lot of n players like to watch like
Kevin Durant Jason
Tatum um those are two of the big
ones uh you met LeBron what was that
like uh that was really cool um
obviously it's LeBron James so um it is
a great experience to be able to hear
from somebody that has achieved the
things that he's achieved and um kind of
get some advice from him did you ask for
a
picture I didn't but there was plenty of
pictures
taken what was it like at Rucker Park
this
summer uh that was just a great
experience um being around a lot of
people that I started to get close with
from being at camps and stuff with them
so it was just a great experience just
to be in a great environment outside
having fun just playing basketball how
many uh players have you played against
who are playing
professionally how many have I played
against that are playing professionally
yeah um well for me it's
kind of like I haven't played anybody
yet that's like professional like in
like high school because that would be
like next year's draft will be people
that I like first played
against but um but just pick up games
have you played against Pro yeah uh at
the Tatum Camp I played like five or six
Pros which was pretty fun and then at
Curry Camp there was like two or three
also how'd you do against those guys I
mean I have my own uh I don't think it
really matters who I'm really playing
against I can always kind of play my
game did you face
Tatum yeah I
did you've seen pretty casual about
going against Jason
Tatum I mean at the end of the day it's
the level I'm trying to get to so um I'm
I'm not really that far off hopefully so
what I'm expecting to get to in a couple
years is not that far off so and so
you're one and done at Duke is what the
normal plan is ually for uh you know
great players are going to hire in the
draft yeah I mean that that's my goal so
well good luck with the uh rest of your
senior year there and uh thanks for
joining us thank you that's Cooper flag
he's 16 years of
age I'm 51 years older than him he looks
even younger than 16 he's
67 and uh he's going to be a freshman
next year at
Duke I like that I mean that's pretty
calm when you're playing against Jason
Tatum and it's no big deal